well this week we've been wrapping our
show with a jeopardy warm-up round but
today
we are really sad to say braden smith
the local las vegas jeopardy contestant
has died at the age of 24. 24. smith was
a
five-day champion and one of the last to
compete with alex trebek as the host
a lot of fans compared him to another
las vegas champion james holthauer
because of his tendency to land on those
daily doubles and his fearlessness in
making those large wagers
smith's death comes about three months
after alex
trebek's death the jeopardy contestant
has said that the
late host was a mainstay in his life
just in these last few months i i think
back
on it all the time and and really savor
each moment that i got to have with him
just even outside the the answering the
questions and everything just talking to
him as a
you know person to person was was really
great
today braden smith's mom posted this on
twitter
we are heartbroken to share that our
dear braden smith recently passed away
unexpectedly
we are so grateful that braden was able
to live out his dream
on jeopardy and the jeopardy also
releasing a statement on his passing
saying the jeopardy family is
heartbroken
by the tragic loss of braden smith he
was kind he was funny
absolutely brilliant our deepest
condolences go out to braden's family
he will definitely be missed braden
smith recently told the ringer that he
actually tried to get on jeopardy at
least a dozen times applying for kids
week and then
teen and college tournaments and
ultimately found
his dream coming true as he appeared on
jeopardy successfully and
such a brilliant young man all of us
today when this
came across our news just really uh
devastated for his family
and uh for the jeopardy community when
you look at at that young
24 years old 24. i was a big fan of his
too i mean
he wanted to become a lawyer and i was
like he was so bright that he definitely
had a great future of that
we'll be thinking about him tonight and
as we head into the weekend and
all of us here at channel 8 our
condolences to his family
absolutely we do thank you for joining
us on 8 news now at 6
30. we're always on at 8newsnow.com and
facebook and twitter and again
all of our best to braden's family hope
to see you back here tonight at 11.
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you